- It's kind of like betting,
like I see your conspiracy
theory and I raise you aliens.
(suspense music)
- My mom sends me articles
about conspiracy stories
on WeChat, one of the most
memorable ones is about flu shot.
So according to this conspiracy story,
all the flu shot are
actually made by aliens.
Apparently, aliens and American
government have made a deal.
Aliens wanted to slowly
change human race to aliens
by injecting flu shot,
at least once a year
just like iPhone upgrade.
- The most memorable
WhatsApp conspiracy theory
that my mom sent me was this picture,
and it was so graphic it was like
a blown up hand next to a phone.
And I'm like, "Mom, why
are you sending me this?"
Underneath it it's like this
big long paragraph about
how talking to your phone is really bad
and like it also has a
high chance of exploding
and so under that my mom
puts, "Salem, please,
don't put your phone up
to your face anymore.
It's bad."
It's like when you get these
messages from your parents,
just say, "Okay."
(laughs)
Don't debate them on it.
Don't say anything just say, "Okay."
And move on.
- So this one, I don't even
have the contact saved,
so it just says a phone number.
(reading in foreign language)
(sped up speaking in foreign language)
(jazz music)
Essentially, what this long-ass message
is trying to say
is that secret Chinese operatives
have created highly advanced technology
that can hide phishing information
in "good morning" pictures,
"good night" gifs, and cute little videos.
So you should not be sending
your friends and family
cat pictures or dog videos,
'cause your credit card
PIN will get stolen.
- So I use Facebook Messenger and WhatsApp
to communicate with my mom.
She will send me articles, videos,
and everything in between.
She automatically sends me, you know,
articles that if I am
walking around barefoot,
I am gonna get sick,
or if I sit on the hot concrete,
I'm gonna get a UTI.
(laughs)
- So, my uncle, all he does
is kind of like surf the web,
and I think he's in the deep web for sure,
'cause he finds weird-ass
videos and sends them to us.
So, like, he sent my entire family,
every person in my family,
and probably other people
outside our family,
this video that claims chicken meat,
that we eat, is actually rat meat,
and it got so bad that, you know,
months and weeks have passed,
and on multiple occasions,
my dad at family gatherings
will bring up this source,
and be like, "Yeah, I heard, you know,
the chicken we're eating is actually rat."
This is wrong information.
When he sends me anything
I still need to respond.
Like, I feel bad, I'm not gonna not reply.
It's his daily, probably,
routine, it's part of his day.
- Because my parents don't trust me living
in America by myself,
therefore they send me
a lot of conspiracy stories
to make me be more cautious.
- I think she was, she
just wants us to be aware
of everything, and take care of ourselves.
- At the end of the day, immigrant parents
are always just trying to keep us safe,
so that's why they send
us all this crazy stuff.
- I think at the heart of
it, it's really this idea
of like "I care about my family member,
and I want them to know this."
And that ranges from a
cute picture of your kid,
to "Something's happening with the CIA
and we need to know about it."
- I think, at the end of the day,
I might miss them when she does stop
sending me those articles.
- I would say, "Keep on
sending 'em, fam, it's great."